hey everybody Doug Walker here and
before you ask that mr. peanut butter on
my shirt like half the time I get my
comments of people saying like you know
what's happening sure what size shirt so
that's what's on this shirt get that out
of the way so okay over the course of
like the past couple months layoff or
winter you know a lot of people been
asking me away think this movie we think
this movie and this job keeps me
obviously very very busy but I have seen
them I just haven't had time to record
my thoughts on them and a lot of big
ones have come out I mean we try to
address the really big ones like you
know infinity war and stuff but yeah I
just haven't had time to record my
thoughts on some of these films some of
them were big like Oscar winners and
stuff like that and some of them are
getting a lot of attention so what I'm
gonna do I'm just gonna go real fast
over like the five or six movies that
came out kind of over that over the
winter and even the past few weeks that
have got gotten a lot of attention and
just giving kind of my general thoughts
on them I'll try to work backwards just
sort of like the most recent to like the
oldest one on the list here but yet
these are movies I have seen I just
didn't have a chance to talk about them
and now I'm gonna talk about real quick
a quiet place this movie is still out
and it's really good a lot of people are
calling it horror I don't know if I call
it that it's more suspense it's more
thriller um but I mean there is you know
there's still monsters trying to get
people and stuff like that so I guess it
counts most you know the story it's
about these monsters that go after they
go after sound it's kind of like tremors
except they're above ground and it's
it's this family that has to communicate
entirely without words they or being
vocal and it's I like films that can
really incorporate silence and the quiet
especially if it's supposed to be
suspense and I think that can't teaches
an audience to it's like okay we can be
quiet during a movie and don't get me
right I yep during a movie - I tried to
be quiet but sometimes I make a joke and
yeah but when a film is designed to be
entirely silent it's I I don't know it's
something we're kind of like shows a
maturity especially when it's a big hit
and
shows that audiences are ready for a
quiet film and they can get more quiet
films even the end of infinity war was
kind of quiet so I like that more these
risks are being taken especially for a
film this was directed I think written
to buy a John karnovski am I saying his
name right but he stars in this to a
good job I mean that this is kind of a
risky type of movie to do in terms of
again just so much quiet in there I mean
this is not something that was sure to
be a hit so I'm glad that was I'm glad
that he has sort of this maturity to
really it's just nice to see him do more
than this look from the office I hate
that look so and I'm glad going in at
gee I didn't know that he directed it
cuz I probably would just been thinking
of that look the whole time like why
isn't he doing that what but yeah I I
really enjoyed the film all the
performances are good it's a good
suspense the only complaint that there's
a like some of the little technicals in
it like the details of like you know
wait that didn't make sound or they
couldn't hear this one or like the the
opening immediately like if you can't
predict what's gonna happen in the
opening then like I don't know I'd be
shocked if you couldn't but while those
were you just kind of waiting for it to
happen but after that it gets really
good and it's I still don't know why the
monsters were entirely CG actually I
probably do it is probably a budget
thing and I get that especially for you
know already kind of a risky film but
may you know what when they rush or when
they run you can see Geum but when
they're just there when they're just
like near a person or getting close like
you know there's nothing there could
they just get a puppet there's something
in it I don't know that maybe for the
sequel cuz I heard they're doing a
sequel but yeah this is a solid film
definitely go check it out I feel pretty
I have a wife so I saw this movie I like
Amy Schumer fine she's kind of hitting
this with me but what she hit so they're
really really funny and I didn't think
this was that funny the two big problems
with it is that
the major one is it's just not written
funny like I can't think of one funny
line in this it's kind of a funny idea
but just and even though a lot funny
people are in this they're just they're
not making this work and the big thing
though on top of that as I said it's a
funny idea but it Amy Schumer is a very
she's an everyday looking person I think
for this idea to work you need somebody
that's an extreme something you know
like remember when Chris Farley was
dancing with Patrick Swayze like that
was funny because of his size and
there's another guy's traditionally
good-looking in him traditionally not
good-looking so seeing him side by side
that's funny
but Amy Schumer is a very average
everyday looking person so I mean I
don't really get white this was funny or
go like a different route get something
like somebody who's like really old or
something get like Betty White or Kathy
Bates something people go WOW why it's
like that's actually like a big jarring
thing if like a purse opposed to go up
and do that I mean that's that's not
something I necessarily want to see but
if that's what you're going for you're
looking for a reaction in which this
movie clearly is and so are the trailers
uh you know that at least would be funny
that at least would get a reaction but
Amy Schumer doing it you know achieve
it's like anyone going up there it's not
like you're going what you know so uh it
didn't do much for me it's not awful by
any means but it was just kind of a
bland forgettable comedy blockers or
should I say chicken block they
know what they're doing that's very
clever advertising uh I thought just for
a run-of-the-mill funny comedy that's
exactly what this was I I got several
laughs I thought was very entertaining
again like a couple days after I see it
I don't think about it much but all the
performances are entertaining and
there's there's definitely one of those
things where it's like you know you're
just seeing this for it to be a comedy
and just kind of check your brain out
and stuff like that but like at the very
end like everybody still kind of comes
together and they're like okay we're all
okay and we're a family and I'm just
like there be a lot more time dedicated
to getting over what a lot of these
parents do
um but yeah I thought was enjoyable I
definitely got some good laughs out of
it I definitely recommend it game night
exact same thing I thought was a funny
movie I thought had just the right
amount of kind of twist cuz you know
going in there's like two twists you're
gonna get at least going into it but but
on top of that they kind of throw in a
few other little surprises so I like
that the the comedy is really funny all
these actors are very very funny
particularly when they try to act tough
in this bar and they try to pretend like
they're grabbing a gun and they're like
talking macho at that stuff if you get a
really good comedic actor actress that
that really really is funny and if
there's some surprisingly good kind of
violence and gore in it and stuff like
that I mean I there's a sick part of me
that does like the kind of humor where
it's like the more painful it looks the
funnier it is but this does push it a
little bit but it but in the best way so
if you're squeamish at all just know
that there there is some gore in this or
I mean not like heads exploding or
anything but definitely stuff like you
know like trying to dig a bullet out and
stuff and it's like but that's part of
the fun so I definitely had a lot of fun
during it
Molly's game I freaking love this movie
this I had no idea really what it was
about I just knew something about poker
but I'm kind of getting more and more
into these crime movies these cry movies
they have a very distinct enjoyable
style and this one does but it's not to
a point where it's like distracting
either it's something where I very
naturally kind of tells this story it
gives you an idea of this person's point
of view and the personality and
everything and there's just so many
interesting twists and turns and it the
way they're telling it which is very
clever is that they tell it after the
book came out and then kind of the core
case that came after it and the arrest
and so forth so it's very clever so it's
not just a telling of the book unless
like an extended version of the book
came out I don't know but there's also
so many good performances in this the
one that really I enjoyed was Michael
Cera as player eggs which
I think a pretty sure has been confirmed
as tobey maguire and even though michael
cera doesn't look like Tobey Maguire if
you close your eyes and listen to him
like it's identical you totally see him
there and and it's just it's it's a
little funny it's very dramatic very
well-written I love the way it cuts back
and forth between sort of the modern-day
with the figuring out talking to the
lawyer and the trial and everything and
then cutting back to what really happens
sort of telling the story and figuring
out if this person really is honest or
knotty oh did she know what was going on
or did she even though she's the
narrator of the story so that guy gives
you a little bit of a bias but but again
that's what's so smart about because you
had the lawyer also giving kind of his
point of view on it too so yeah it's it
sounds like it's truthful I mean I never
know anymore but it's one of those
things where it's like it's an
interesting story either way and I
greatly enjoyed it if I had one nitpick
I say that the main actor is paid
playing Molly she's good she's not great
I feel like this could have had like
kind of a powerhouse performance around
it but then again me maybe that's the
idea maybe she's supposed to be a little
bit more quiet and reserved and to
herself again not really knowing if she
really did this stuff or not but I don't
know I feel like even that could be done
a little bit more with a little bit more
intensity but maybe not I don't know
it's a good performance don't get me
wrong I feel like this could have been
like a really great performance but me
maybe that's not what's needed maybe
that's the ideas like she did kind of
slip you know under the radar and then
suddenly people are accusing her of this
thing and because they don't know we're
you know like they don't know if she
could actually do this stuff or not so I
greatly enjoyed it it's a fascinating
story but check it out if you haven't
yet annihilation this is from the guy
that directed ex machina which is also a
really great movie you can definitely
tell it's the same person it has a
similar ending slash twists ish and I
don't know it's actually one of those
movies I wish ended like maybe
thirty seconds earlier again that's
nitpicking but no this is one of those
films were it's like again it's really
quiet it really builds up the suspense
all the characters are relatively
interesting and when they come to
whatever decisions they make in the film
it you know why the only thing it's an
epic but the only thing that drove me
nuts is that because for anyone doesn't
know there's it's kind of like a rival
there is a weird thing and people have
to go in to figure out what the weird
thing is and how to explain it because
everyone that's gone in has disappeared
or died or got lost and communication
gets taken out and everything but yeah
okay so they're sending in this group of
people and there's like a paramedic and
a couple other and there was no military
going in until Natalie Portman came in
and it's like wait you were gonna send
in no military which I know they send in
a ton of military before but going in
with none is weird especially when
people keep disappearing so that's once
or twice there's little things like that
where I'm kind of like well why didn't
they do that why don't they just have a
long cord you know tied around them when
they go in and they can cuz they get
lost immediately when they go in it
plays with the mind but it's like didn't
nobody think of just a long cord that
keeps going and going and going so again
those are nitpicks the actual film
itself has a lot of interesting ideas
kind of unique ideas that play around a
lot with past present future and
identity and character as well I'm not
usually a huge Natalie Portman person
but she grew on me on this light like
she was she was pretty solid it's not
one of those performances where she has
to do a bee cry scene or anything like
that like she just plays it very
straight and and it works I feel like a
lot of the actors and this really do a
good job of that like they really bring
something to it that sometimes can be
big but it's never too big it's never
distractingly big and there's a goddamn
bear in this back see I shoulda said
that cuz now I'm gonna build it up cuz
everyone that talks about this movie
talks about the bear so I'm probably
building it up but it's got the out
of me
like I think I've been that scared so
it's like a little kid watching Jurassic
Park like I was just like
so yeah I won't say too much after that
but yeah it's it's a good movie it's
good sci-fi you can definitely kind of
see elements they're taking from but
they turned into something unique they
turn into its own thing and I really
really enjoyed it definitely check that
one out cuz I don't know if it got that
much press so definitely go see it shape
of water so yeah it's time for me to be
a dick again I didn't like this movie
I'm sorry I didn't hate it by any means
it's not an awful film at all but like
the minute this thing starts I could
tell you what every character was gonna
do when they were gonna do it how they
were gonna do it well
okay the fin the fish sex scene that I
couldn't quite protect it's like maybe
the one new thing in this but yeah and
and even that would be okay if I mean
most people know the story behind this
kind of a monster romance film and it's
obviously going against prejudice and
stuff like that there's one prejudiced
jerk who's always like no we must keep
things separated we ma he's clearly
wrong and he's just there to be the dick
and all of that probably would have been
okay if the chemistry was better and I
was actually really excited for this
chemistry because the woman this you
know she can't talk the fish person
can't really talk either and so they use
sign language but the sign language
doesn't go on for very long and they
don't communicate much and she suddenly
like I know we got to get him out we got
to get him out there and it just seems
out of nowhere so everything becomes
about the escape and then after the
escape it becomes about them just
wanting to bonk like it's not even there
really was not that much romance and I
feel like for a movie where you're going
to make out with a fish person you need
to really buy that romance you need to
buy that chemistry and they don't it
seems more it seems more focused on
showing that prejudice is bad which cool
great we haven't seen that yet but even
visually light Deltora stuff is just
visual you know it's a visual Marvel I
mean like Hellboy 2 I didn't think was
that great a movie but tell
it was just phenomenal uh and even this
just kind of felt like his lesser stuff
okay the city's dark cool the fish guy
just sort of looks like the fish guy
from Hellboy you know I mean that
nothing really nothing really grabbed me
about it I think the only scene that was
interesting but both visually and I
guess what the idea was the fish egg
scene which even then wasn't like I
wasn't watching like oh you can't do
that because that's what a lot of people
were saying it's like no it's a very
visually nicely shot clever idea the way
they do it and that's about it like I
said by no means hated it
I just for me I could predict everything
every emotion everything was gonna
happen and there wasn't a strong enough
chemistry for me so I know a lot of
people love it awesome I mean I'd like I
said I can't see anything really bad in
this film I mean don't don't go screwin
fish or anything like that but yeah I
mean it's one of those things where if
you love it
awesome it's not a bad film to like I
just didn't like it i Tanya I love them
when I see a movie that is based around
a time where like I was alive and I saw
this stuff unfold so this was really
cool to see and it was funny to see and
it's told in just the right way this
movie is not told really from one point
of view it's kind of all the various
stories from all the various people it
even opens up admitting that you know
this is a very disjointed several
different stories talking about this you
know that they're not claiming this is
100% true they're just going off of the
confessions of these people which do not
often link up but they try to go for the
you know most interesting parts and
there's a lot of interesting parts and
there's a lot of funny parts there's a
lot of tragic parts all the performances
are just so good you know we're watching
we're watching a Margot Robbie I think
it's how you say your name mushy she's
great in this
but there's one scene in particular
where it she was like and that's why she
got the nominations well she's putting
on makeup before she goes out
and performs and it's just one of those
where it's like we've watched it and we
were like but that's the Harley Quinn we
wanted to see like that the Suicide
Squad that's not her fault
at all I liked it she did fine but it's
like that's the character we wanted to
see just that performance she gave
looking in the mirror and it's just so
great and so uncomfortable and just the
whole movie in general just had this
really really bizarre a kind of feel to
it which I think very much represents
these people and I like a film that has
a style that really matches the story
it's trying to tell like there's
definitely some movies where they just
want to eat always hear this style over
substance what it really has to be a
style meets substance I like they feed
into each other and that's what this
movie does they really really feed into
each other and the one downside I don't
know people bring this up but okay so
they have a professional skater going
you know doing all the stuff and
everything when she's performing and
fair enough I mean this is like want the
greatest skaters ever I mean so you need
a really good skater to do this but they
CG Margot Robbie's head on there it
looks bad it looks really bad and I have
no idea that's a thing or not if people
talk about that or they don't but yeah
it does not look good that's like the
one thing and it is so distracting like
you want to get into the emotion of the
scene but you are just constantly
looking at how the lighting on her face
does not match the lighting on her body
or the rest of the scene so that's
really distracting but everything else I
thought was really really great a sort
captured I felt like he captured
everything about that about that weird
bizarre period in Olympic history you
know where suddenly like there was I
mean I don't think there was much
Olympic scandal before that nobody even
thought of ice skating before all this
happens so it's funny that this suddenly
through all this attention on ice
skating I mean now it's like one of the
major things in the Winter Olympics and
and it just captured why was interesting
why it was strange
my favorite line the whole thing I think
is in the first three minutes where
they're talking to a guy from hardcopy
he says yeah
we represented sort of a news outlet
that everybody that all the our news
outlets look down on and then became
what a brilliant line like as soon as
that line came I'm just like I you got
me I love you movie this is gonna be a
great movie that is a great movie
and like I said it's not a style over
substance film like they really do help
each other out and they feed into each
other and they make a really really good
film so I definitely go check that out
too guys that's about it hopefully over
the year when I see a movie I can give
my thoughts you know the on camera or
with Rob or whatever and yeah I can go
into more detail about it rather than
just like you know rather than just
doing nothing I guess
so yeah I'll do my best to keep getting
reviews out there I'll try not to do too
many these compilations and I'll just
see in the future
you